joining us now Council of the presidents
from Kellyanne Conway I'd be negligent I
really don't want to dignify this
ridiculous dinner but I think I'd be
negligent if I didn't ask your thoughts
I really truly it's it's so insulting
and crude and I try and always flip the
tables if this was a conservative
comedian saying this about any liberal
women woman what would the result be
Sean in some ways there was very little
that was surprising on Saturday night
though the faux outrage from some people
who looked down at Twitter all day long
and see the likes of Sarah and Ivanka me
insulted this just happened right in
front of them where they were all
gussied up so they couldn't deny it I
mean in some ways it was just another
day at the office they know that we're
insulted handily but it doesn't make
some people any less miserable or us any
less powerful and dutiful to the jobs
that we have on the behalf of the
country that we love I actually think
both events Saturday night really helped
President Trump first he got to go to
Michigan and tell he was in Washington
Michigan searching the economic progress
of security that hit the historic nature
of what's going on in Korea and then the
event here in Washington helped him as
well because it fed right into all of
the all of the cynicism the skepticism
that a lot of Americans have about the
mainstream media writ large they have a
14% of it let me say something I spent I
spent tonight trying to find out how
much Michelle wolf is paid and nobody
will give me a straight answer and I
called three people who were on the dais
who actually picked up the phone and no
one will give me an answer to said they
had no idea there are any to know about
the media to know about anchors and
reporters a financial hole looks to
considering everyone cares about mine
well hold on but hold on the reason I
say this is we're told this is a
scholarship dinner and yes you should
pay for your for your entertainment but
I feel really badly for those students
the president the vice president met
them at the White House they took
pictures with them the other day I had
occasion all of American events to meet
these scholarship winners I feel sorry
for them
because
they were almost an afterthought that
night and I don't want anybody to say
this was about them this is about the
First Amendment when the president of
the White House Correspondents
Association stood up and said an attack
on one journalist is an attack on all
journalists well folks think about this
is an attack on one woman or two women
an attack on all women I'm glad I didn't
interrupt you that's a powerful line
North Korea history in the making
nobody saw coming yes it is Iran's
intelligence President Trump was right
the unprecedent alliance Israel United
States the Saudis Jordanians Egyptians
the Emirates it's unbelievable
what peace through strength can do when
we have about no that's right it's
incredible Shawn and it is certainly
owing to president Trump's leadership
and his vision and also his patience the
relationships that he's been able to
build with leaders across the world in
the first 15 months of his
administration really the first year and
a half since he was elected has led us
to this moment and folks don't
underestimate the power of North Korea
South Korea literally comin together
holding hands and saying that decades of
war will will couldn't just be swept
away could end also North Korea has
agreed to stop doing his nuclear test to
allow inspectors in which is key to go
back to the same time zone as South
Korea a lot of progress there and it's
Donald Trump's leadership many many
critics of this administration are
giving him the credit for that
oh yeah these are amazing times but I
gotta ever the president credit I doubt
it
all the best to you and Sarah Sanders
tonight and Ivanka as a matter of fact